hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday Monday May 14 2008 eeen how
are you what is going on with you oh
really
that is interesting do you know I went
to way from Mother's Day by the way
happy belated Mother's Day out there for
all the women out there who love others
and yeah there's nothing bored poor
they're loving again the way they go on
and on about mothers remember that on
Father's Day Jesus Christ that's like a
[ __ ] blurb you know at the bottom of
the stock exchange oh by the way happy
Father's Day anyways anyways you know
what I mean they're there the
quarterback they get all the [ __ ]
glory is a father you're the left tackle
you know protecting their ass and nobody
gives a [ __ ] they don't even know when
you get traded
nobody's sitting in the stands wearing
your Jersey right who the [ __ ] buys a
[ __ ] left tackles [ __ ] goddamn
Jersey is it the guard is it the guard
position is that the one that's all
important is that the one I'm sure
everybody who plays fantasy football had
never competed in their life will let me
know that that's not exactly it's not to
tackle its the garden tour isn't to
tackle I don't give a [ __ ] so we went to
the the getty villa which is a museum
and evidently it's by this guy john paul
Getty and john paul Getty evidently was
a really rich guy and like a lot of rich
guys he didn't pay any taxes evidently
he went out he bought a bunch of art
john paul Getty let's see didn't pay
taxes let's see if this comes up with
anything
the reason why Jay Paul Getty refused to
pay 60 no the billionaire who refused to
pay kidnappers all that was good to
kidnappers the tragedy of the Getty zone
I feel bad what happened severed ears
what happened so far we can't open this
page as it's still an active case the
billionaire girl refused to pay
kidnappers to save his grandson's life
what oh man oh what a cold bastard the
upcoming film all the money in the world
when the [ __ ] did this come up oh it's a
film that doesn't mean anything let me
do is based on a true story and then
everything else is going to be [ __ ]
right it's like that movie hidden
figures they start like taking real
people and then they combine them
together and they amalgam like take
three people and they combine them into
one person and then people start coming
up to you when they start quoting movies
like that like they read a [ __ ]
history book it's like no you went to
the movies you ate gummi bears
and popcorn that's not reading this is
coming from someone who doesn't read Oh
Kevin Spacey played [ __ ] [ __ ] Jay
paul Getty the upcoming all the money in
the world has been garnered and
gardening a lots of buzz for the scandal
around it a month ago the filmmakers dis
of Jesus Christ not that skin I want to
hear about the [ __ ] kids life all
right but the scandal boom proposed
based on 1973 john paul Getty the third
the 16 the 16 year old grandson of the
oilman Jay paul Getty then said to be
the world's richest man worth some 1.2
billion just around 9 point 1 billion
today was kidnapped in Rome his
abductors demanded 17 million bucks but
this guy probably had in his breast coat
pocket although rich people never walk
around with money you know they never
haven't they'd have a [ __ ] heaven
which his family wouldn't pay leading to
his captors to cut off his right ear
the ordeal coupled with terrible neglect
ruined the boy's life at just 24 he
ended up
lies as as a result of a drug overdose
as it turns out all the money in the
world could not save him
Wow I wonder what he was probably
thinking well if I pay this guy I'm
gonna have to pay everybody I'm not
giving you seventeen million you realize
how many Derrick's that could by yelling
at his daughter well [ __ ] Christ afraid
that's one of the few things in life
that's three making a baby making a baby
is free you know provided you can find a
woman that doesn't need to go on a date
and have a relationship first other than
that it's probably one of more expensive
things you do how are you everybody this
is the Monday morning podcast it's a
little bit late because I was out
celebrating Mother's Day I realized for
the nine millionth time in my life I am
NOT a museum guy unless it's like the
Museum of cars drums I would literally
enjoy seeing a Museum of refrigerators
that started with ice boxes you know and
they just you know record on 18 [ __ ]
teens the first motorized cars brought
ice box down the face right watch one of
those things I went to the
harley-davidson museum I obviously
enjoyed that you know but I'm not a
headphones guy you know you get to the
[ __ ] Museum I'm gonna tell you guys
what kind of guy I am by telling you all
the guys I'm not and then you can do
process of elimination okay
what you've learned on this [ __ ]
podcast already I'm not at museum guy
I'm not a headphones guy then a few
podcasts back I told you I was a
breakfast guy all right I'm the kind of
guy that tells you what kind of guy he
is and he isn't whether you asked or not
and I'll go on and on and on and on and
on and you won't even get to speak I
said got a guy at you
I don't like corner museums and you get
that little [ __ ] recorder and then
you have like the headphones and [ __ ]
you got to walk around and look at every
goddamn exhibit I just
blow through it and get a gist and if
anything catches my eye I'm fine with it
you know I don't need to look at every
goddamn knick-knack and see what like a
brooch look like in the Middle Ages so I
went to the Jay paul Getty Villa and I
imagine 17 million probably put that
pool in so well then a lot of people
would give their ear for that so maybe
he was right I don't know I don't
[ __ ] know anyways that's what I would
do if my parents were that [ __ ] rich
my parents will that goddamn rich I I
would I would die of a drug overdose or
something might do go out and get a job
you know but what sucks is when you're
that level rich they can always hang it
over your head so I would probably rebel
and just go my own way be one of those
[ __ ] morons you know instead of
having a [ __ ] jump through every hoop
of Sun you gotta take fencing classes
and all that [ __ ] that makes you a
gentleman learn how to sail you know all
that rich white [ __ ] that if you're in a
[ __ ] will you know what I mean first
of all someone that has that amount of
money for the most part you know as far
as the movies tell me when I sit there
eatin you know I don't eat gummy bears I
always go with the [ __ ] peanut M&Ms
you can't get the ones that don't have
peanuts in them when you get the plane
M&Ms if you actually eat a movie size
bag of one of those you are so full of
sugar like you start having like
disturbing thoughts you got to get the
peanut M&Ms I think or I'll get the
chocolate covered covered almonds hey
I'm a [ __ ] peanut M&M guy I'm not a
plain M&M what did I start saying what
kind of guy I am this is some
middle-aged [ __ ] you realize that when
you start talking about that [ __ ] you
know trying to carve out you know hoping
somebody someday is gonna make a statue
of you in a taffeta
do you realize how many people you have
to
kill in a press in order to get a statue
made out of you
you know if you don't have an athletic
ability but even then you got to crush a
lot of homers dunk a lot of balls score
a lot of goals throw for a bunch of
touchdowns is you got to do a lot of
[ __ ] to get a statue everything's a lot
so if you're in power you have to press
a lot of people you have to kill a lot
of people you know or maybe died
tragically it's not worth it you know I
mean even if you like [ __ ] one of
those athletes that gets gets a statute
because then what happens you know you
miss your kids growing up while you were
out there [ __ ] you know getting your
Gordie Howe hat tricks what were they
doing huh they were out there getting
kidnapped getting their heads chopped
off so you know I guess I guess what I'm
trying to say is it's a price that
everybody pays yeah so I went through
that museum and the only thing I liked
there a giant ball of play-doh that for
some reason took somebody 20 years to
put together and I can't imagine how
much their significant other much the
complaint you know I know as a guy I
don't know if my wife just started doing
that with the play-doh after a while I
go yeah well it keeps her happy yeah she
I was gonna say she's out of my hair but
I don't have any yeah other than that I
know it's just a bunch of [ __ ]
weird-looking statues nobody looked
happy back in the day you know
everybody's just [ __ ] grumpy that's
because most people died by the time
they were like 20 like you like not like
people have a problem contemplating
their own mortality because you can you
know even if you're a [ __ ] you can
pretty much live a good 70 years so you
don't have to think about it for a while
you can stand there on your smartphone
all right you take a picture of the menu
and then text what should I get to your
[ __ ] boyfriend of your girlfriend
whatever your deal is but deck 10 you
know people like you got a fever and you
just died you know you fell off
something you know your leg turned
[ __ ] black you just you just [ __ ]
people
died back then you know they didn't just
keep going the way we do once you [ __ ]
you know anything happened to you back
then you've just [ __ ] died mothers
given birth died babies in EM died two
for one right there you know it really
is amazing you got a you can really have
to appreciate the level of [ __ ] that
has been done globally for us to get to
this level I guess maybe it's science
you know coming up with aspirin and [ __ ]
like that you know this is even dumb for
me
I'm literally stepping outside myself
listening to this it is a funny story
for you real quickie alright last night
I went down to a comedy store they had
the memorial ceremony for Mitzi shore
the woman who created started the The
Comedy Store and ran it for decades and
basically because of what she did I got
to all of these comedians that I watched
that made me want to be a comedian was
because that she started the place and
looked out for him and all of that stuff
so I had to go down there you know even
though I only met her twice one time I
didn't really even meet her I was
auditioning for and they were like this
is Mitch she's Sean she barely looked at
me and I went up on stage and I don't
know how much time I did but she was
gone by the time I got off and her
review was he hasn't ready as much as
that pissed me off she was right I
wasn't ready
and then years later I got in and I
talked to her briefly so you know I
didn't want to go up you know I hate
when people go up on a memorial service
to talk when they didn't [ __ ] know
the person so unfortunately I didn't get
to know her but I definitely more than
profited off of all the work that she
did and all the comics before so thank
you to all of them so anyway so I'm down
there and uh you know getting to watch
all these people talking telling least
hilarious stories
about mitzi in the Comedy Store back in
the day and this person comes up to me
and goes hey you know I guess like an
audience member or something was I was
ain't you know comedy groupie or some
[ __ ] was going hey I was in [ __ ] uh I
was at you show the other night
you trying out a bunch of new stuff I
said you know few things here or there
when new but you know for most part you
know it's proven stuff and she goes what
about that me to stuff and I said I know
I've had that since you know [ __ ]
started going down and she goes would
you like to hear my opinions of that
material as a woman as a female she was
would like to hear my opinions on that
material as a female and I just go no I
walked away I just loved that would you
like to hear my opinions as a female
what does that mean as a female you are
female could you give me your opinions
as a hermaphrodite you know how would
you do that I have no idea I don't I I
I'm just I'm sure that person is a nice
person I didn't take offense to it but
it was one of the easiest questions I've
ever had to answer and I just walked
away and to her credit she left and I
just walked away but um I think that's
just a symptom of you know just the
internet now you can comment on [ __ ]
YouTube videos you can comment don't
[ __ ] you know [ __ ] spew every
thought you have a [ __ ] having a
podcast I'm literally talking to myself
so maybe that's what the [ __ ] it is but
I've never in my life I've never had a
conversation like that was [ __ ]
bizarre oh yeah by all means why don't
ya you you punch out my [ __ ] that's what
I was waiting for a complete stranger to
help me out with my act could I have a
complete strangers set of eyes on this
[ __ ] and by the way the material I did
it [ __ ] killed it [ __ ] killed that
night let me guess your opinion is you
didn't like it oh maybe that's why I'm
doing it
do you haven't noticed I'm kind of an
[ __ ]
anyways plowing ahead did anybody watch
the f1 race over there and [ __ ] in
Spain place I would love to go someday
what an exciting race they got to do
something man they got to do something
to these cars where there's some sort of
passing in the front row so like Lewis
Hamilton just [ __ ] he he just got to
the corner first he was in pole position
and then that well that was it the one
exciting thing was Ferrari pitted early
and they went to the medium tyres you
know you know I remember that the one
the one with the white lettering I'm
medium is because they always say white
guys are boring average whatever you
know that's how I remember those then I
always forget like yellow soft and super
soft is the pink right and I'm not gonna
get into the metaphor about that but
anyways the only exciting thing was when
uh Sebastian Vettel pitted early and
changed his tires and it was just like
is he going to be able to catch him and
that answer that was answered pretty
[ __ ] quickly with a resounding no and
somehow Lewis Hamilton helps it's such a
shitty [ __ ] start is [ __ ] he's
back at first place again and I don't
know why it bugs me it was just cuz
years ago I remember when like you know
he was asking his teammate to [ __ ]
help him out he's when he had the the
[ __ ] Days of Thunder Ricky Bobby [ __ ]
going on with that [ __ ] guy what the
[ __ ] was his name back in the day Nico
Rosberg
they didn't get along so Nico was being
a teammate for him a few races earlier
and then when it was flipped and Nico
was winning the race and they needed
Lewis Hamilton to do something you know
basically do the same thing that Nico
did for him he [ __ ] refused which is
not what you're supposed to do you know
he went Kobe Bryant on it I want the
ball and ever since then as I have [ __ ]
it [ __ ] this guy I don't like this guy
with his red private jet alright I'm
stalking him I I don't like literally
not like the guy but that was just one
of those things it's just like you know
I don't know so anyway so I've somehow
being German and Irish guy I should be
for the [ __ ] Mercedes team right I'm
mostly German but for some reason I'm
rooting for Ferrari maybe because it's
just every time every [ __ ] year it's
like Mercedes wins the two years that
I've been watching it I think that's
that's what it is
I don't know Louis would you like to
hear my opinions of your driving as a
male who doesn't drive competitively
so anyways I'm up here in San Francisco
that's why I had early flight today
that's why I the podcast is very late
today so up here it was funny I checked
the weather in San Francisco and right
before the window opened I said gloomy
and shitty and that's exactly what it is
although the sun's coming out right now
this this everybody talks about Seattle
how it rains in his [ __ ] blew me and
all I I don't know I have had more sunny
days on shows in [ __ ] Seattle and
Portland combined than I have the Oh
every time I've come here it's just
always just sort of you know you always
have to have a jacket
I can't estar today store here in San
Francisco I wouldn't try to [ __ ] with
the burritos cuz everybody's got that
lockdown but I would definitely have
some sort of jacket and a hat store it's
just [ __ ] miserable here and I'm
staying at this hotel I'm doing one show
a night 7 p.m. show so I love it I'm an
old guy I love the 7 p.m. one show done
at 9 o'clock I come home I get in a bed
I [ __ ] relax you know I do my rosetta
stone a little bit of French you know
not hurting anybody just an old bald
white guy right but anyways you know I
want to do my big birthday is coming up
50 turning 50 June 10th next [ __ ]
month so I wanted to drop the last
couple of pounds and I went downstairs
they got this shitty [ __ ] gym it's
the worst do you have a gym yeah we have
a gym no you don't the gym is smaller
than my room and I have a basic [ __ ]
room with two queen beds the Jo maybe
the gym is
same so I think they just took a room
and they just I got they got one that
thing will you sit down and pretend
you're riding a bicycle which nobody
gets on that right people who wear
makeup and read US magazine when they
work out get on that [ __ ] thing then
they got an elliptical great but they
only got one and right next to it is a
treadmill and right next to that is a
treadmill and then you're at the wall
they got a couple of kettlebells they've
got some dumbbells they got no bench you
know so I guess you're just doing
shoulders and curls you know I don't
know what and then they got a couple of
dirty bands down there those elastic
pants well fortunately I brought some
[ __ ] with me but um I don't know I gotta
start making demands here I'm gonna be
in a hotel the gym has to be bigger than
my hotel room can there be more than one
cuz you know what's gonna happen you're
gonna go down there and it's just gonna
be [ __ ] you know you get down there
in the morning it's just gonna be those
gym rats down there just [ __ ] all
over those things sweating and [ __ ] it's
gonna be gross but fortunately it's San
Francisco so I'm just gonna walk the
hills I think that's what I'll do
oh and how about those Celtics I taped
the game I didn't see one second of it I
was over at the Jay paul Getty Pavilion
whatever the [ __ ] I was the villa which
I you actually when I fly well I do solo
flights I fly out of Burbank a lot and I
go all the way out past
cámara low I was called Camarillo
because at Rich came a real punter for
the Patriots and then I come down the
coast all the way down Malibu ready to
get the Pacific Palisades you get on
with Santa Monica Airport and you say at
the at the Getty Villa helicopter
whatever whatever whatever Santa Monica
Tower helicopter whatever whatever
southbound along the coast at the
Getty Villa requesting [ __ ] eastbound
transitions are you [ __ ] airspace
sorry I'm out of it this is why I never
do podcast when I fly I don't know what
the hell happens
I flew Southwest and there was no
[ __ ] stand-up on the flight it was
great no bad stand up on the flight and
cruise right up here great flight and
all that and anyway so yesterday I was
at the [ __ ] the Getty Villa and
that's when the Celtics game was on I
missed the whole [ __ ] game and I
don't know how we did it but we beat
them and we won by 20 points which is
amazing but I'm thinking that might have
been like a [ __ ] hangover game
because no yeah they would do what they
were idle that's right because they
swept Toronto so game 2 is [ __ ] huge
game two I actually think if we win Game
two having watched three Celtics games
this year
if we win Game two we I am I think
actually I think Game two is a must-win
because because they got LeBron James
LeBron James one of the biggest and
nygma's I've ever as far as like what
that guy is done versus the level of
[ __ ] that he gets I just I don't
understand it is a people ever gonna
forgive that guy for taking his talents
down to South Beach alright so he went
down there he was part of a couple of
pylon [ __ ] teams but then he went back
to Cleveland and won them their first
[ __ ] championship since [ __ ] Jim
Brown in 1965 that should have been the
end of the movie the man redeem himself
but I've never seen a guy no matter what
the [ __ ] he does people find a reason to
[ __ ] all over him
and what kills me is meanwhile Kobe
Bryant demanded free agents every
[ __ ] year for Shaq out of town cost
them a [ __ ] championship cuz Shaq was
still in his prime he went to Miami they
won there never gets any [ __ ] oh it
doesn't get nearly as much [ __ ] I don't
live for the life
yeah I don't understand why the LeBron
James gets so much [ __ ] he's literally
willing this team into the into the
Conference Finals
so whatever other people don't
understand that guy I get I get who that
[ __ ] dude is and I think if we don't
win Game two we have no shot at went in
this series and even if we do win Game
two because of LeBron James I don't know
I got 200 bucks on this series though
somebody talked me into was like did I
ain't got a [ __ ] bag if we went to
games I'm going to be thrilled we got to
the Eastern Conference Finals
you know without Rick Robey and Eric
fern sting who's that guy we got from
the Cavaliers who's up I already don't
remember his name the other guy there
moe Howard that we got him [ __ ] Utah
I missed every Celtic game this year
just about except for like maybe two
I know Jalen Brown and Rozier and Tatum
have been the story Kyrie Irving there
we go
I think next year we're gonna look
pretty good be great to get another
championship before the Lakers rebuild I
don't know we'll see we'll see what the
[ __ ] happens but I should probably you
know what's great though is the fact
that I have early shows I think I can
actually catch a lot of the games this
week maybe get back into it's [ __ ]
hilarious watching the Celtics for the
last two years and now they're like get
Allah well I can't say legit shot to be
killed yeah you know sometimes I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm talking about
this week why don't I just do a little
bit of advertising here how about that I
went old school by the way
I brought all my [ __ ] up here brought
all my podcasting stuff up here
something I haven't done in a while and
you would think if I would to bring all
my equipment up here I'd actually have a
decent podcast but I but I haven't all
right simply safe everybody it's
important to protect your home with a
home security system how can we protect
your home and your privacy that's what I
love about simply safe they obsess over
details like no other home security
company here's an example simply safe as
a camera you can control from your
you know what I in the future they're
gonna have something that tells you if
somebody will coming up your walk is a
person or a robot that's what I'm
guessing but they want to protect your
home and your privacy so they came up
with this brilliant idea a privacy
shutter for their camera now simply safe
what I don't know what just happened
there in example it simply safe has a
camera control can control from your
phone but they want to protect your home
and your privacy so they came up with
this brilliant idea a privacy shutter
for the camera I don't understand how
what what what is your face looking out
of the camera and then the guy breaking
and concealed are you worried about
somebody on the bus looking over your
shoulder and seeing where you live going
oh I recognized that shrub I don't get
what do you I don't know what's going on
right now now simply safe wanted you to
be able to hear the shutter click so you
know it's closed they wanted to have it
have a light on it so you could easily
tell when it's on and they needed it to
work for the entire lifespan of the
system so simply safe got to work
testing different metals and hinge
designs for months and months the result
an effective home security camera with a
thin lightweight aluminum privacy
shutter that will work every time I
don't understand what they're protecting
you from what's the privacy it's that
kind of attention to detail that sets
simply safe apart it keeps your family
safe I don't know what they did but it
seems like they work real hard on it
simply safe isn't just a home security
it's home security done right check out
simply safe today's that's simply safe
dot no simply safer calm yet simply
safer calm to learn more about simply
safe today all right simply safe bird
calm I could read that a thousand times
and I wouldn't understand what the [ __ ]
that is all right me on these biondi's
going to a [ __ ] Museum dudududu
mazzani's beyond easily
it's not a mausoleum sorry I needed to
rhyme look at all the old [ __ ] isn't it
nice go out to the cafeteria and order
some rice it tastes like [ __ ] and it's
100 bucks
cuz you're eating at a [ __ ] museum
with a bunch of snotty kids I don't like
little boys by the way now that I have a
daughter if they're always [ __ ]
jumping around making all kinds of noise
and [ __ ] bumping into kids I really
don't like him the amount of times I've
fantasized about punting one of those
little bastards across the [ __ ] room
you know I had my daughter there at the
Museum and I just knew these [ __ ]
kids you know and they're doing that
dumb [ __ ] little boys do to try to get
attention talking in weird voices and
jump around flailing their [ __ ] arms
good lord
as much as I can't stand my eye I
realized that I was one of them alright
me undies you've definitely heard me
talk about me undies
you know the fun comfy undies that feel
just as good as they look to those you
haven't tried them yet listen up you can
get incredible underwear it's sent to
you Dora the undies meaning no more
hunting around for the perfect pair at a
crowded store and eventually settling
for good enough this is how spoiled we
are as human beings no going out and
buying underwear is considered to be a
form of hunting the undies is so sure
you'll love your first pair that if
you're not happy they'll do whatever
they can to get you went to the right
pair and if they can't keep them and
they'll refined you so it's really so it
really is risk free to try the best
underwear ever and if you're already
part of the undies family tell your
friends about it through their referral
program they'll get a discount and
you'll get store credit it's a win-win
still not sure well the undies has a
deal for my listeners first-time
purchasers get 20% off their first pair
of me undies and free shipping has 20%
off plus free shipping and a guarantee
that you and your me undies will be very
happy together get your butt over to me
and ease calm and treat yourself to get
you 20% off your first pair of free
shipping on a percent satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies comm / /
that's Mandy's comm / /
all right next one Dollar Shave Club
dude Joe did you see barstool sports
[ __ ] retweeted that clip of that guy
from the Celtics Lakers 34:30 why the
Celtics gonna win because they are
because it's all tics are the balls his
[ __ ] high-pitched voice if you ever
shower a brush your teeth or try to make
your hair look presentable alright two
out of three in bed here's some good
news
Dollar Shave Club has a lot of stuff to
help you out Dollar Shave Club yes that
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best you name it shampoo conditioner
body wash toothpaste hair gel even a
wipe that'll leave your tush feeling
tingly clean you'll be a big fan of
their amber and lavender calming body
cleanser doesn't that sound wonderful
after you try it for the first time good
luck finding a product like that great
at the store well I'm sure you could it
isn't we're selling the convenience of
it well it's not [ __ ] over step by
bouncey at Dollar Shave Club like you
can't find that a store you can find
that anyways but you [ __ ] wants to go
out there you already get your underwear
delivered to you why not have all the
other [ __ ] that you use before you put
on your underwears all of Dollar Shave
club's products are made with top-shelf
ingredients that won't break your budget
you feel the difference plus shipping is
free with your membership and here's a
great way to try a bunch of Dollar Shave
club's products for just 5 bucks you can
get their daily essentials static kit it
comes with body cleanser one wipe jaw
they're amazing butt wipes their
world-famous shave butter and their best
razor it's six I wish I had some of
those one wipe Charlies now this [ __ ]
hotel has that tear your ass up toilet
paper you know you let [ __ ] that so much
see-through you got to use like half the
[ __ ] roll so you can't see your hand
on the other side of it and they're best
razors a six blade executive razor keep
the blades
coming for a few more bucks a month and
add in shampoo toothpaste or anything
else you need speaking of your next
month for a limited time only use the
code burr at checkout to get five
dollars off your second month of the
club
that's code Burpee you are are at
dollarshaveclub.com
to save five dollars on your second
month join the club
today and lastly but certainly not least
these are not an order of popularity I
just read them as they come
headlining once again stamps calm
everybody use poast use don't use the US
Postal Service is an important tool for
any business buy and print official u.s.
postage for any letter any package any
class of mail using your own computer
and stamps comm makes it easy they'll
send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
out of the [ __ ] blue the best class of
mail based on your needs no need to
lease an expensive postage meter and
there are no long term commitments I use
stamps comm I'm gonna be using it when I
send out my my posters over to Dublin
and London England I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure it out so can use you so can you
and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale go to
stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in BER
that stamps.com enter ber there you go
yeah speaking of which this run of dates
here is my last tune-up before I go over
there and do these those two huge shows
which in a good way I am nervous about I
want to make sure that I have a good
show so I am going to be doing a bunch
of [ __ ] this week and then that'll be
what the end of this week will be the
18th alright so I still have it still
have like a two week gap I'm gonna have
to do a lot of [ __ ] popping and doing
some shows to make sure I stay on my
[ __ ] game here
all right in the eye of the beholder
oh [ __ ] why did I write that down oh you
know what because since my Bruins lost
in the playoffs I ended up some friends
want to get together they wanted to play
that metallics Vitalik a song I had the
beholder from off of the injustice for
all album I believe it's track number
two and so I've been listed all the
spittle iike and I never used to listen
to them I went the other way I listened
to more [ __ ] warrant then I listened
to Metallica I liked single bass drum
playing and I just like it was just too
raw too fast for my ears I never got
into it so now of course I'm going back
down bliss - oh my god this [ __ ] is
unbelievable and I actually sat down I
took a video of I'll take a video of it
I'll post it I actually wrote the entire
drum chart out in my own chicken scratch
I didn't put down the hi-hat or mind
emailing the crash cymbals just just so
I could make sense of this song and what
I noticed about Lara's playing is he's
pretty religious when it in the chorus
and then you know with a lot of time
changes obviously on that album
so those drum parts are pretty
repetitive but in the [ __ ] verses
that guy is just like flying by the seat
of his pants so he has all these
different little things that he does and
really really fun album to listen to and
so I sat down and I wrote out the whole
[ __ ] drum chart for that song it's
like four or five pages long because I
was trying to memorize sound like this
is gonna take me for [ __ ] ever why
don't I know how to read drum music so
why don't I just sit down and write this
[ __ ] out and I'm really glad that I did
but then I have to watch out like like I
get in this [ __ ] so then all of a sudden
it's like well I'm gonna write out the
drum shot for shortest Ramat I do the
whole [ __ ] album anything to keep me
out of the bus I'm not gonna lie to you
I had one drink Saturday and one drink
Sunday small ones and very small what's
and now I'm back on the wagon again so
that's how I'd like to drink I'd like to
really think about drinking now before I
do it which is what I think about is the
next morning and how awesome I have felt
not drinking so I had a very very very
[ __ ] incredible tequila and it wasn't
even a finger like as far as how much
I've poured maybe it was a finger and I
just sipped it
it was nice I really enjoyed it didn't
even have ice on it
nothing just really nice and then that
was it and then I was done and then I
had a water right next to it I merely
got one if I go to the water that that
[ __ ] makes me not go like I'm gonna
have a [ __ ] bunch of these so anyways
I think I'm going to the goal anyways
it's just kind of chill this week and
you know I've been talking to a couple
of my buddies who have just been
starting to slow down a little bit with
the drinking and it's just more like I
don't know how you look at it you know
because I am not by any means a young
man anymore and that [ __ ] will [ __ ]
age you and kick the [ __ ] out of you and
life is hard enough I don't need to be
adding that you know so anyways speaking
of which I found a healthy place near my
hotel and I just walked down there
got that stuff and all that [ __ ] you
know so I guess I got it I got it it's
time to pass the baton okay partying is
a young man's [ __ ] game and I'm done
with it
there I said it I want to be done with
it I should say every once in a while
though every once in a while you know I
go to that one big college football game
a year I go to the Rose Bowl and you
know whatever maybe three four times a
year but other than that I'm [ __ ]
done with this [ __ ] okay I hope anyways
alright ex wife pretended to be my
parole
officer okay a billy blue balls
I wish making this story I wish I was
making this story up but I am NOT well
how would she pretend to be your parole
officer without you knowing she must
have done it to somebody else
somehow she must have [ __ ] you over
anyways I'm in my early 40s and had been
married for 12 years unfortunately the
marriage ended in a divorce last year
what when she found out you were in the
mob how I fight you're married for 12
years it's guys like a responsible
[ __ ] dude he ends up going to jail
even though we had no children my wife
got to keep the house in the divorce
settlement of course she did but there
are always victims and the guys always
the [ __ ] [ __ ] divorces and alimony
are expensive so for the past year I've
been renting a townhouse well dude
you're doing fine you rent a townhouse
in this little community where most of
the other residents are elderly couples
oh I see see waiting for someone to die
and you moved in there I loved it
I enjoy it just don't steal their
[ __ ] Social Security checks I enjoy
living here and even though most the
other residents are older there is a
nice community center that has a tennis
court yeah you're [ __ ] beating
everybody feel like a young man and a
pool and events during the week and
sometimes even live music so all in all
not too bad of a situation well about
three months ago I met this great lady
and we began to date my ex-wife found
out and did not take it well that I was
back in the dating pool
so quickly yeah because why get know how
well you know she just got the [ __ ]
house so she went around to all my
neighbors pretending to be my parole
officer Wow
well they're all witnesses why don't you
sue her for defamation of character she
can you do that she claimed that I am a
registered sex offender and she was
following up to see if I had gone around
door to door to admit to my neighbor I
was a sex offender oh you got to sue the
[ __ ] out of this woman obviously I did
not do this because I am NOT a sex
offender and so all the neighbors said
no
I not disclose to them my sex offender
past I had no idea my ex did this until
a week later I got a letter from the
community board residence requesting
that I move out for being in breach of
state laws requiring me to disclose my
sex offenses all right dude all you need
is a lawyer brother all you need is a
lawyer this is easy
this is [ __ ] easy I of course went to
the board and told them that they were
all lies but they did not believe me
because I could not prove I'm not a sex
offender yeah you can go get your
[ __ ] record I found a website and
search my name and of course nothing
came up but they wouldn't believe me
plus the dude this is so simple this is
so simple sue your wife and sue this
[ __ ] say you're gonna sue this old
[ __ ] folks home if they kick you out
plus they said even I was telling even
if I was telling the truth
and then my ex is lying they don't want
me in my community because I hang around
people who wouldn't lie about such a
transgression
okay well that's that's kind of fair on
their part I do not want to move
especially because they said they did
not they don't have to give me any sort
of refund and I'd be liable to pay the
remainder of my lease I'm not sure what
my options are and to involve the legal
team will only add to expenses well
you'll send them right back to her and I
still may have to move what do I do
thanks for listening and go [ __ ]
yourself well provided you're not a sex
offender I would get a [ __ ] lawyer
and tell the guy listen you got a
[ __ ] you know what do they call that
working pro bono or some [ __ ] working
for the sag minimum I would absolutely
get a lawyer I would absolutely get a
lawyer and I think you're the the judge
in your divorce case who handles your
alimony and all that [ __ ] should know
what this woman did I would press I
would find out whatever whatever legally
you can do whatever a law she was that
can't be [ __ ] legal to do that and
then you got all that [ __ ] that they do
all the emotional stress and how this
[ __ ] affected you and I would sue the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of her that is all
that's what I would do absolutely get a
lawyer
abso-fucking-lutely get a lawyer Jesus
can Christ did you see this this is why
this me to [ __ ] what you've created this
thing now what you don't need any proof
[Music]
you know what I'm saying I'm all
forgetting all these bad guys you know
outed and all that [ __ ] but you can't
just create a system where you take due
process and you throw it out the [ __ ]
window okay
because of [ __ ] like this and I know all
the hype out there right now is that
women are victims and they're all these
[ __ ] angels and the truth of the
matter is is there's [ __ ] and
there's vindictive people out there who
have dicks and sometimes they have
vaginas you just can't have people going
around [ __ ] doing stuff like this and
you know if we're really going to go
into a future where everything is fair
you have to start you know women have to
be responsible for their actions you
can't [ __ ] go around and do something
like that over some petty [ __ ] to
[ __ ] ruin a guy's life like that I
mean do you realize like how vindictive
that is that is un-fuckin'-believable
and I like I I'd be honest with you I
would never in a million years man how
long I sat there and thought I could
never come up with something as bad as
that and yeah I don't need to tell the
guys listen to this that women can
effortlessly do that hell hath no fury
like a [ __ ] woman scorned especially
when they're not held [ __ ] respond you
know I just love how women can get away
with like destruction of property
there's even a commercial on TV where
this guy's going through some sort of
breakup and this woman is just throwing
all of his [ __ ] out the [ __ ] window
computers and all that and it's played
for comedy it's [ __ ] considered
hilarious you know what I mean what's
fine I can roll with that but you can't
you know have some overbearing guy
screaming at his [ __ ] wife
late for comedy anymore I guess you used
to be able to do that but you know sir
if you were actually innocent of all
everything that she just did there I
would absolutely you know what - why
don't you start a startup
start a startup
- get a [ __ ] lawyer you give me the
link dude and
I'll throw 500 bucks at it sue the [ __ ]
out of her if she [ __ ] did this to
her sue the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of her good
luck to you alright you know and I'll
tweet out the [ __ ] link and everybody
just get on this thing and let's get
this guy a [ __ ] lawyer so he can get
on with his goddamn life he's not doing
anything wrong according to him okay as
long as what he's doing he's telling
truth other than that I think I might be
given $500 to a sex offender kidding all
right crazy wife Jesus hey ladies can
you guys write in too because I want to
keep this balance I don't want this to
be a [ __ ] sausage fest here all right
all right crazy wife I have a wife I met
overseas all right well you know what
that's your [ __ ] fault all right you
know you're gonna go over there and
they're gonna have their [ __ ] wooden
shoes in their awful teeth I mean
wouldn't you know you're gonna be over
here and bring her around the Buffalo
Wild Wings what do you thinks gonna
happen anyways he goes on 25 and she's
22 we're not technically married since
we didn't finalize the paperwork
okay then what is the problem we just
had this ceremony which is the only
reason this question is worth asking
otherwise I just deal with it okay fair
enough by now it seems like the
possibility of dealing with the
consequences of dropping her is the
better option
okay this already feels like you've
already made your decision you just want
me to back it up we were dating two
years she was normal but since we got
married she flips out and gets
hysterical over little things to the
point where I feel awkward to just be
next to her even when we're alone my
first guess is she got married too young
and she's freaking out because I would
guess most of her friends aren't married
yet at 22 I think she must be bipolar or
something she's still overseas I'm about
to submit to the paperwork to get her a
visa but I'm at a critical point in my
future career
that's very competitive and I can't deal
with any of that
much less put up with it for the rest of
our lives
when she freaks out she says things like
she wished she hadn't married me and
[ __ ] me and all that which is one thing
but then she says she wishes she were
dead and that she wants to kill herself
I'll do do you know what I would take
that paperwork and I would go down to
Staples and say hey
I'm in the market for a paper shredder
do you have the cross-cutting one maybe
yes anyway you could plug it in I could
just try it out and then when they plug
it in you put that marriage contractor
in there and then look at the staples
guy and be like yeah I mean it's nice
but I don't I don't think I need I don't
think I like it and then just walk out
all right
because dude I think you're gonna end up
like the guy in the last one living in
an old folks home with some crazy
[ __ ] woman anyways he goes I can find
someone else but my friends and family
know we got married and we're expecting
to have her over soon your parents
aren't gonna give a [ __ ] is it better to
bite the bullet and admit I made a dumb
choice rushing into marrying this girl
before I have to deal with the divorce
settlements and absolutely is keep in
mind her culture is very old-fashioned
than her friends and family would look
down on her and she might never date
slash marry again not your problem not
your [ __ ] problem she met one
foreigner she can meet another and in
case you're wondering I'm an average
looking white dude she's a solid eight
dude I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a
[ __ ] all right okay dude this just in
the fact that she's not even there I
mean whatever the [ __ ] you was the
greatest thing ever the situation that
you're in is so easy just don't sign the
papers you know just call it just and
just be totally honest with her just say
your mood swings are so crazy that I you
know I no longer want to marry you and
let her flip out and let her scream and
yell and say she's gonna kill herself
and all that too you know you can feel
bad for her but you know you live once
okay you only live once
okay and being married is difficult even
when you marry the right person
forget about somebody that that's that
emotional erratic erratic and she's
saying I wish I never got [ __ ]
married
so early in the marriage that you
haven't even submitted the [ __ ]
papers I mean Jesus Christ dude take the
hint and you're not happy and you've
already made the decision you know what
you're worried about dude it's gonna be
weird for about [ __ ] four or five
days
it's like shaving your head people like
dude what the [ __ ] and after five days
they can't remember what you look like
with hair dude walk away [ __ ] dump
her and just go to the bar and get
yourself a really nice [ __ ] IPA right
a really nice [ __ ] beer whatever the
[ __ ] you want and just sit there and
just know that you your whole future is
is it's just wide open wide open
anything can [ __ ] happen okay and
that's it dude walk the [ __ ] away and
God bless you for writing in before you
end it up on that other guy situation 12
years in and you got that [ __ ]
nightmare please start that start up
dude I'm not giving I'm not kidding I'll
give you a [ __ ] 500 bucks alright
worried about my future hey Billy 8-ball
I love the comedy the podcast all of it
I have a problem and was wondering to
get some of your advice I am the oldest
of six and I am a junior and I am a
junior in high school and soon entering
my senior year everything is going fine
but the only thing is that I don't want
to go to college well then don't go I
personally think college is a scam and
unless you want to do to do specialized
profession
unless you want to do a specialized
profession Ayana percent agree but
besides that it's nothing but an
institution to make debt slaves alright
well okay okay relax relax it's also a
great place to meet women you know it's
a great it's a great social thing too
you guys I want to leave my home state
and move out to Wyoming have become a
correctional officer the only problem is
my parents want me to become a lawyer I
don't want
come a lawyer I want to be I want to do
law enforcement I didn't think I should
go about telling them I love the podcast
and go [ __ ] yourselves
I would say mom and dad I have something
important that I need to talk to you
about don't worry nobody's pregnant and
I'm not on drugs okay start with that
joke
so they'll relax it's not life or death
just something I need to talk to you
about sit them down and say listen I
don't want to be a lawyer I want to be
in law enforcement and then that's it
and let them react how they're going to
react but you do what you want to do in
life I wouldn't have such a bleak look
about you're definitely informed but you
don't want to get so dark that you bunk
people out that you say stuff like dead
slaves there's also people that go to
college for one year and they meet
somebody else and then all of a sudden
they build a computer and they make
[ __ ] billions of dollars there's all
different ways you can do it there's
also ways go to a [ __ ] Community
College for two years and then transfer
into the [ __ ] more expensive fancier
school the piece of paper is still going
to say that you graduated from there
you're gonna gonna cost you half as much
there's a bunch of ways to do it all
right but I would just sit down just
tell your parents what the deal is just
let them know yeah I said that you
didn't get anybody pregnant and you're
not [ __ ] on drugs so they can [ __ ]
relax sorry Boston or Chicago for LA hey
Billy burger tits I'll have you know
that I'm back into working out I'm back
doing push-ups I don't have Berger tits
I have slider tits thank you very much
I'm a 28 year old engineer from the
North Shore the eff went to school in
Boston now work in Boston and I live in
Somerville saying the rent that used to
be called slum ervil's now it's all
[ __ ] hipsters and cupcake places and
all that it's amazing I started dating
this girl a little over a year ago who
lives in Somerville - but it's from
Chicago ball butt is from Chicago she
just got a new job in Chicago and is
moving back there in a month we talked
about this happening before and kind of
just decided to play it by beer she said
and deal with it when it comes well it
came and short-term solution is that I
will stay in Boston for the next year
and do long distance relationship
alright wait a second
I start dating this new girl a little
over so you've been in it for a year
you're 28 okay so I guess my problem is
that I'm kind of at an age where I
should buy a house instead of throwing
money away in rent so if I decided to
move to Chicago I think we would settle
down there and stay there but I love
living in the Boston area granted I've
never lived anywhere else so who knows
what it will be like I'm still very
close with all my high school friends
who all live around here my old man's
always on me about buying a house here
and wants to fix it up together if I
move to Chicago that doesn't help do I
choose the girl and life most likely in
Chicago or stay here save up for a house
be close to friends and family and try
to convince her to come back to Boston
so a few years ago at the Wilbur will be
at the Garden Show in October with the
boys can't [ __ ] wait dude thank you
thank you for that I don't know dude is
she the one that's what I would ask
myself I would this is what I want you
do this over the next [ __ ] year why
don't you go out there and visit Chicago
and see if you like it and see if you
still like that person the great thing
is you don't have to make this decision
right now if you wait another year to
buy a house no biggie okay as far as
making a rash [ __ ] decision dumping
this person or buying a place in Boston
or buying a place out there before you
know about I would just go out there and
I get the lay of the land
I get the lay of the land there
I can tell you Chicago is an incredible
City I love it
the food's amazing the people are
amazing the sports there are incredible
but you know who's kidding oh you're
always going to be a Celtics Bruins Red
Sox a Patriots fans you just have to be
but now you got the sports packages and
all of that but I can't tell you since
1995 I've been living behind enemy lines
as a sports fan I don't think it'll be
as bad in Chicago I just lived New York
in LA so it was like [ __ ] Yankee fans
and Laker fans so it's just that
[ __ ] also during the curse of the
Bambino so but that is a big decision
and I don't know how much you're into
this person all right I would think it
was your soul mate it would be a
no-brainer and you just go wherever the
[ __ ] she was going within reason though
because you could meet your [ __ ] soul
mate you know if they go into some
[ __ ] you know you're not gonna want
that but Chicago is not a [ __ ] yeah
I mean I obviously I can't make this
decision for you but if you think I
don't know you know when you know you
know when you're with the right [ __ ]
person so if you feel that then I
wouldn't you know worry about going
somewhere where she lives because it's
Chicago that's a good move
Chicago's [ __ ] great one thing I went
from Boston to like [ __ ] I don't know
Albany
no offense Albany buddy what the [ __ ] I
don't see what I can't make this [ __ ]
decision for you but I wouldn't buy a
house or move out there until you
figured it out how about that your high
school friends but you guys are all
gonna get married and have kids and then
you're never gonna [ __ ] see each
other anyways I can tell you that or
barely see each other or [ __ ] go out
and have to be home by 9:30 or 10
o'clock for the sitter which is a really
healthy life which is why I wished you
know I got married
kids a long [ __ ] time ago I wouldn't
be [ __ ] out there running around
staying out all hours of the night which
is what I would do because I didn't want
to go back to the empty lonely hotel
room so I would stay out as long as I
could
tell us about ready to fall asleep I
would just come into the hotel room and
just [ __ ] collapse so there you go
there's my advice from a [ __ ] [ __ ]
comedian all right that that was my my
opinion as a male for me anyways alright
go Celtics game two Red Sox and Yankees
tied in first place which is [ __ ]
awesome
Red Sox was on fire now we've cooled off
now the Yankees are on fire tied for
first place and maybe their a-game
Ahead's right where you want it right
where you want it it's no fun being the
first place if the Yankees aren't there
as a Red Sox fan okay and we've played
each other six times there were three
and three so hopefully we'll get to you
know battle it out in September maybe we
both make them make the playoffs we meet
once again in October that's what I'm
hoping for
and hopefully the Lakers get [ __ ]
good again so we can beat their asses in
the final next year God knows they'll go
out and [ __ ] get a whole bunch of
free agents who doesn't want to play out
their racist la it's always summer and
you can [ __ ] movie stars all right
that's it as opposed to racist Boston
where you got a deal with the witness
and for the most part do you go walk
around [ __ ] sixes and sevens well I
guess you'd [ __ ] 10s but there's not as
many tens in Boston and then in the in
the best tents the top-of-the-line tents
they all leave they all go to the major
system like New York or [ __ ] LA and
then New York and LA claim them as if
they're from there but they're not like
New York City is a free-agent town as is
LA there's just a bunch of [ __ ]
people coming in there so anyways
alright that's it that's the podcast for
this week
I will check in on you on Thursday
thanks for all the kind notes about the
Bill Hader interview I would like to do
more of those in the future
that's it if you haven't checked out
Barry yet on HBO promoted against might
be my favorite show out there right now
all right that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Thursday